Did you see the tweet from the president last
night?
I mean, is this guy nuts or what?
In other news we got for you today,
a new sex scandal has hit Hollywood,
the national debt is at an all-time high
and it looks like congress is heading for
another shutdown.
After police burst into his home and shot
his two dogs in a botched drug raid.
Phil?
Phil Conners?
It's me!
Ned!
Ned?
Bing!
What are you doing Ned?
Going to the protest, how else are we gonna
get change?
You should come too!
Oh no, that's, no thanks.
Beginning of the end of Donald-
The Russia story we expected tonight-
North Korea has launched a ballistic missile-
Inappropriate sexual behavior-
Is the president a racist?
Wants to spend big money on infrastructure
but the key-
Did you see the tweet from the president last
night?
I mean, is this guy nuts or what?
In other news we got for you today,
a new sex scandal has hit Hollywood,
the national debt is at an all-time high-
burst into his home and shot his two dogs
in a botched drug raid.
Phil?
Phil Conners?
Ned?
Bing!
What are you?
Didn't we do this-
Wait a minute what day is it?
It's February second, Groundhog day!
No no no no.
Phil you should come to the protest with us!
Beginning of the end-
The Russia story-
North Korea-
Sexual behavior-
A racist?
Big money on infrastructure-
Did you see the tweet from the president last
night?
shot his two dogs in a botched drug raid.
Ned!
Phil?
What day is it?
Phil you don't look so good.
Don't mess with me pork chop, what day is
it?
It's February third.
No, it can't be-
oh what?
It's February third, we talked about this
yesterday, don't you remember?
So you've been out here protesting three straight
days?
Three straight days?
We've been protesting every day for a year
how else are we going to get change?
Oh god!
Wait this is worse.
This is so much worse.
Bing!